рекрути пити таке називаю bundeswehr на
праките на нову руку створ це серіал
про буднього не травневих казармах його
герої
молоді хлопці то дівчата віку ви вирішили
5 в армії на зйомку серіалу про курс
молодого бійця то наяву рекламу
міністерство оборони не матч він і б
тротилом пожвавись і мільйонів євро
ми битви щити право близькість
армійську службу за контрактом плакат з
ареалу uuid ринок шоу-руму бундесвер у
єдиного рекламного офісу німецька армія
ще в центрі берліну я гнівно ти чекав
сюди може за цієї осі охочі
про з перших рук ясна то себе про
prophecy не і перспективи в армії після
завершення холодної війни чисельність
бундесверу пусти нас курачі волосся в
шатуре міністр до оборони ними чини
заявила про фундаментальні зміни і
просування інвестиції для закупівлі про
оружня чи то для зрощення чисельності
армії вони летять по white крім tmf жиру
спочатку розвороту харчування закупівель
матеріалів та бюджету
нині настала година персоналу нам slide with
hot це ж сустейна вас коротше не
дуже сальності буду сферу
адже других лизніть і виходу суб'єкта
приватного організованого війська взяти фон
ельдштайн обдерти
проте повішку ви правда німецька армія
з косово риб я спала он уроки в тому і
підсумок годинник разом весь канал фільму
незабаром черга а ще дня до берлінського
шоу-руму уганда сферу приходять у 30 до
40 видвидовача
чивер за кошиком для них дорого в
армії відкрита на ремені з людиною і
про блешня половина серпня і просто
хочу поспі когось ся ришта доводиться
dice серйозним випробуванням з дроту
кар'єри в армії за слова макаренка
шоу-руму понад усі німецької армії шлюбу
з оселилися з інформаційних
технологій та санітарів прикольний зв'язок
bundeswehr ці робота давати тут місцям
туди просто опираєшся складеш супер
ству
закриваєш опис на пракіті робочого дня
і забуваєш про все вчора був а
приносиш швидкості людям я зіставивши
всі наші солдати пар ікона не що у нас
у краї не абсолютно польша класно
політично система вільна до цього
різним suspense твоїм дозвольте
захищаємо у ЦПШ подруг
бундесвер про панду бай тут можна
гостей для почту йде на перетинати її
карі заданому social язичних
випитувати речі знімки Петро мати
перехід на повністю контрактну армію
від села спочатку ще бонда сферу і треба
Чи доведіть конкурувати з цивільним
робота дощами засвічених молодих
фахівців